allora non so come cominciare questo
video però mi scuso se c'è questa roba
in testa però effettivamente stiamo
andando a momenti della quarantena che
diventano problematici per persone con
capelli delicati ecco quindi non mi
scassato gara fatti i capelli chi se ne
frega è successa una roba che con letti
ton non è un click bait non è un click
bass assolutamente perché il buon rocco
ovviamente non vi sto a specificare
quale rocco perché tanto è 1 cioè quanti
ce n'erano ha reagito al mio video del
da frigerio così prendi colori video
correlati sapete che facevi dovere nati
ogni tanto quindi dovevo andare da papi
j
su youtube ad arrivare al rock molto
difficile il video in questione è questo
qua da farvi j
a rocco siffredi
[Musica]
rocco su youtube è un problema però va
bene vediamo qui non è una vera e
propria reaction in realtà però sono
contento del fatto che rocco abbia
apprezzato il mio video godendosi le
patatine chips
perché a noi la patata piaceva becco lo
sappiamo quindi oggi io volevo rendere
omaggio al buon rocco ringraziandolo
innanzitutto per aver reagito al mio
video e già che ci siamo visto che rocco
mi segue
ma secondo me sono molto più io lui poi
lo fai una domanda a tema è una domanda
molto personale quindi una partitina
robert lee che nel mentre che parlo
potrebbe aiutarmi a capitano alla sirio
rocco ho una domanda da porle molto
personale e della seguente cercherò di
essere molto family friends in questo
video sarà molto difficile
allora ragazzi parlo anche un po tutti
voi perché coinvolgono punti che sta
facendo ha purtroppo poi tutti conoscete
il video la mia prima relazione che ho
avuto e verso la mia prima volta di
conseguenza la mia prima volta come
sapete ormai già tutti non mi esaltava
quindi e questo è stato un problema nel
senso che la mia prima volta io andavo
troppo pensavo troppo ok quando voi
pensate troppo
ribadisco questo concetto quando voi
pensate troppo il sangue va al cervello
e come tutti sappiamo perché tutti
abbiamo studiato il corpo umano se il
sangue si trova nella zona del cervello
non sta nel caso e quindi questo
potrebbe risultare un problema del
momento in cui stai per effettuare una
prestazione sessuale con una persona
questo è successo ebbe avevo già
raccontato la mia prima volta la mia
prima volta che ero esattamente in
questa stanza era esatta
niente su quelle jolie che vedete alle
mie spalle quante ne ha viste quel letto
una vista e quale è stato il problema il
problema è che ho pensato troppo perchè
ero preoccupato della mia prestazione
che poi secondo me quando se tutto
sbloccato non è andata manco ma però
quello potrebbe giudicare solo il nostro
rocco quindi parte questo poi tutte le
altre volte sono andate bene però la
primissima ero ansioso perché volevo far
star bene il mio partner e quindi
pensavo tanto e pensando tanto non
metteva che avete capito tutti nudi lo
ripetiamo purtroppo ragazzino cola non è
stata l'unica volta è successo un'altra
volta
e c'era adesso la raccontano basta basta
giocare ma stato chiaro che io capitano
oggi non è non è giornata c'era questa
ragazza che non era di milano quindi è
venuta a milano per uscire con meta
usciti tutto a posto poi mentre eravamo
fuori stava chiacchierando un certo
punto mi fa ma quindi stasera io non so
dove dormire mi aiuti a trovare uno
della faccia e casa lorenzo cinque
stelle allora e le ho detto subito molto
timidamente guarda che vivo da soli o un
led tv o via casa mia e ho detto questa
cosa e ha detto va bene è venuta a casa
mia purtroppo non in tutti i sensi io ho
fatto un signore ho detto tu dormi nel
mio letto io dormo sul divano sono state
a parlare allora va poi leva nel letto
io vado sul divano a dormire quello
sarebbe stato il momento per presentarsi
alle 3 di notte nudo in camera mia no
ovviamente no però per fare una cosa del
genere c'è nel senso almeno provare a
dire ma se non c'è avuto le palle
nel senso che ero lì che mi crogiolava
nel mio essere una rablà ho detto dai
porco il demonio vai e va tanto è vasta
chiesto di dormire h è per forza un sì
vai
no non sono visto non tepic sono un
deficiente un deficiente non sono citati
le niente non abbiamo fatto niente
giorno dopo si sono svegliati e fatto
colazione e lei se n'è tornata a casa e
io ma società partner che un mesetto
dopo un mesetto dopo perché poi comunque
lei ha apprezzato questa cosa tra
l'altro mi fa comunque sia uno
spettacolo di ragazzo gentile
carino credo abbia apprezzato il fatto
che non necessariamente sono andato da
lei la notte anche se lei voleva questa
cosa comunque ha accolto il lato
positivo della serie questo quando nel
maniaco ecco anche se ci sarebbe
piaciuto a entrambi fare questa cosa
quindi sono stato con colpirla ma questo
lato è stato apprezzato in realtà io ho
tirato testate al muro e basse comunque
il tutto sto casino io sono poi andato a
trovare lei che abitava lontano quindi
sono andato e sono rimasto là un paio di
giorni anzi tre giorni fino a che arriva
la sera
dormi a perché quella ha dormito con me
dormiamo e finalmente si arriva a quel
punto lo sto dicendo con un colino
improponibile per ora per chi se ne
frega se arriva a quel punto a fango la
saab giovanni non brucia verso quindi
abbiamo passato la prima notte dove non
di nuovo barca tutta non si è fatta una
sega in tutti i sensi
poi il giorno dopo invece tutto apposto
giorno dopo tutto a posto ho invitato
anche warnock sono andata bene tutte le
altre volte la tab e nissimo cioè voglio
dire palco demonio però la prima volta
all aprile la numero uno sto 1 de merda
non riesco a fare per la prima volta nel
suo faro campo perché ci penso ci penso
e dico voglio essere c'è insomma
prestante perché poi magari insomma ci
penso tanto sarobe pensando confluiti
edward cullen ha avuto il suo problema
anche me l'ha detto no e quindi ragazzi
niente la mia io gli scarpini per
concludere tutta sta facendo al discorso
è che quando a me frega della persona
con cui sono c'è nel senso voglio
costruirci qualcosa perché sono
innamorato di questa persona
la prima la number one non funziona cioè
non riesco non funziona che cacchio non
sono veri e basta dirlo anche basta
cambiamo argomento però poi tutte le
altre va benissimo cioè per fecero
giorni si tutti insieme incredibile
dell'altra volta sua incredibile donne e
credetemi però la prima non non la prima
è sempre quando ci tengo è perché non
sempre però che non è che non ci tengo
io non magari non ci tiene banco le
volèe stoffa quello qui non è che
stomaco lo sfrutta le occasioni non
vuole fare quello
e quindi chi se ne frega di costruire
qualcosa lei è d'accordo io sono
d'accordo e quindi funziona la prima e
chi se ne frega sto dicendo
nel caso di costruire qualcosa ok quindi
una prestazione deve essere buona e
ricorrente e quindi la prima importante
eccoli 404 penne not found dopo tutto
sto casino
la domanda che pongo al signor rocco e
ragazze nel senso come fa come si fa a
sgomberare la mente in modo tale da non
far confluire insomma che poi va tutto
bene con il fatto cover perfetto
meraviglioso fra la primissima mi gira
il caso che la prima da ricordi non è
bella la prima volta tra ricordi sempre
ci deve essere un modo porca vacca
sblocca non lo so io lo sblocco solo i
personaggi su tecnico in queste si può
valorizzare di più la prima volta
generale dove sono contento perché porca
vacca per questi sono i contenuti per i
quali siete iscritti al mio canali
lasciate un commento facciotto su che
cosa ne pensate
vabbè
[Musica]